hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich möchte euch heute ein
rezept zeigen von dem ich schon seit
dezember ungefähr die anfragen habe und
zwar werde ich heute einen schokokuchen
machen mit erdbeeren und ich bekomme
wirklich schon seit dezember sind bild
geschickt ich weiß nicht woher es stammt
ich hab's auch nicht mehr gefunden ich
hab echt lang gesucht aber ein dass ich
einfach so einen schokokuchen mit einer
weißen creme und erdbeeren und ich habe
bisher nicht darauf geantwortet und habe
immer gesagt ja ich mache es nicht macht
noch einfach aus dem grund weil für mich
geht einfach nicht dass man etwa im
winter kauft aus dem grund weil es dann
eben spanischer advance sind und man
muss sich einfach mal ganz logisch
überlegen ist man die app besser song
beginnt jetzt im mai mitte mai ende mai
und wenn man etwa im dezember kaufen
kann sollte man sich überlegen was
steckt eigentlich auf den erdball drauf
also wieso kommen die überhaupt so
knallrot und groß und prächtig bei uns
an und wie werden sie über angebaut und
ich möchte da nicht mehr auf das thema
eingehen sondern verlinke euch gleich
zwei videos unten in meiner infobox da
wo info steht und zwar könnt ihr da
einfach mal nachschauen wenn sich
interessiert ich find's super
interessant weil man einfach mal sieht
wie ebenso ettwein gezüchtet werden wie
sie gepflückt werden was eingesetzt
werden muss damit sie eben schön
knallrot werden und nicht vertauscht und
verteilt bei uns ankommen und natürlich
auch welche menschen dahinter stecken
das dann züchten müssen und wieder so
die arbeitsbedingungen und so weiter
sind bei uns ist es so also wir kaufen
und dann unsere erdmann hier oder was
uns noch mehr spass macht wir gehen
einfach direkt aufs erdbeerfeld und
pflücken unsere app bance l war das gibt
denke ich in jeder stadt oder so in
ländlichen regionen auf jeden fall gibt
es überall
diese deutschen effelder wo man dann
selber drauf den kann mit der ganzen
familie
wir machen es dann immer so da hauen wir
uns dann echt den bauch mit app planvoll
und und gern da mein mann und meine
tochter meine eltern sind immer dabei
können daran die app den flecken man
kann dann so viel essen wie man will
kann dann noch welche pflücken für zu
hause und es ist echt nicht nur einfach
so dieses flicken sondern dass ich
einfach ein tolles erlebnis für die
ganze familie immer verbringt die zeit
in der
und dass ich einfach was tolles waren
diese erdbeeren selber sammeln und
selber pflücken kann ich meine diese
hier sind jetzt gekauft weil zb unserer
erdmann im garten noch gar nicht fertig
sind diese noch gar nicht reif
aber ich bin es einfach schön wenn man
das eben so mitnimmt und das auch den
kindern mal zeigt wo die erdbeeren
überhaupt wachsen wie so heißen die
erdbeeren weil es auf der erde wachsen
hart und ich finde sollten einfach mal
gemacht haben
und ja die videos sind auf jeden fall
sehr interessant für uns ist
beispielsweise nicht nur wichtig dass
wir selbst alle produkte kaufen also die
produkte die jetzt gerade saison haben
sondern auch dass wir regionale produkte
kaufen
es gibt zum beispiel im supermarkt bio
rucola und wenn man da mal aufs etikett
steht da italien und für mich ist es
dann persönlich kein bio rucola mehr
weil dieser rucola vielleicht biologisch
angebaut wird also nach bio standard
aber ich denke mir dann okay da muss
jetzt von italien bis nach deutschland
geliefert werden und diese dieser ganze
transport die abgase das ist für mich
einfach kein bio mehr und lieber kaufe
ich dann in rucola der vielleicht nicht
bio angebaut ist aber eben aus
deutschland kommt oder bei uns wächst
der rucola zum beispiel im eigenen
garten
dann warte ich einfach bis da wächst und
dann kann ich mit den schönen flecken
der welt brokkoli schmeckt so viel
besser und das ist einfach dieses thema
mal überlegen muss also welchen weg
müssen die ganzen früchte und obstsorten
hinlegen um bis nach uns zu kommen
klagte er bis zu uns zu kaufen
deutschlehrerin klar gibt's bei uns
keine ananas ich meine gut wenn es mit
dem flieger waren so weitergeht wenn
vielleicht in 20 30 jahren auch hier
ananas gezüchtet werden können weil du
einfach bei uns das wetter so trogisch
wird aber ja ich werde euch mal auf
jeden fall in sessel saisonkalender für
obst und gemüse auf meinem blog
veröffentlichen
ich finde das hat manchmal daran
orientieren und dann werdet ihr auch
sehen dass es bei mir ihn nicht nächster
zeit viele rezepte mit erdbeeren
himbeeren heidelbeeren geben wird also
mit so ganz viel saisonalen produkten
und jetzt möchte ich euch gerne meine
torte vorstellen die ich heute machte
ich es mir
nicht ganz schnell hergestellt sehr
einfach und schmeckt total lecker und
zwar ist es ein leckerer schokoladiger
teig mit erdbeeren drauf mit einer
joghurt schicht das finde ich immer ganz
lecker und dann als topping kann man
entweder die streusel vom kuchen
benutzen oder eben eine schöne show
geschichte und ich würde sagen jetzt
gehen wir einfach an den ofen und ich
zeige euch jetzt die zutaten für den
teig
ich habe hier drei eier 125 gramm zucker
60 gramm mehl 50 gramm kakaopulver back
kakao und keinen körper und 40 gramm
speisestärke hier habe ich noch
eineinhalb teelöffel backpulver hier
habe ich noch etwas vanilleschote
gerieben durch eine mühle
ich habe hier 100 milliliter
mineralwasser mit sprudel drin also mit
kohlensäure und hier 60 meter neutrales
warum benutzt nur eigentlich wasser
mineralwasser und kein normales wasser
weil da kohlensäure trennen weil es den
teig luftiger macht als stilles
mineralwasser
manchmal können stattdessen auch fanta
oder sowas nehmen hat man noch ein
bisschen mehr geschmack drin aber dann
finde ich es zu fußball wir haben ja
auch hierzu ich habe meinen ofen schon
vorgeheizt auf 190 grad ober und
unterhitze und habe hier mein backblech
mit backpapier ausgelegte ihr könnt
natürlich auch die bakterien nehmen die
habe ich aber leider zu hause vergessen
und hier habe ich noch meinen back
rahmen und den hab ich auf 24 cm
eingestellt wenn ihr jetzt eine
springform habt oder den bug rahmen und
eine andere größe machen wollt gibt's
auf meinem blog auf salehs torten mit de
eine umrechnung tabelle bei meinem
russischen zupfkuchen kann ich aber auch
gerne hier unter dem video verlinken und
da könnt ihr euch das eben ausrechnen
für die jeweilige springform größer als
ihr könnt diesen kuchen diese torte auf
jede größe hoch oder runter rechnet
übrigens auch in 18 attacken oder in der
32 einfach die umrechnung tabelle nehmen
und die zahl dann mit den zutaten
multiplizieren also mal nehmen
jetzt werde ich einfach den teig
zubereiten und geht es gegen anti
küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt es
natürlich wie immer auch mit einem
handrührgerät machen
aber so ist es eben viel einfacher für
den teig gibt jetzt erst die eier in die
rührschüssel
und gebt dann nach und nach den zucker
mit dazu und nach das ganze mit der
küchenmaschine auf höchster stufe so
lange rühren bis es richtig schön weiß
cremig ist dann gebe ich das wasser und
das öl mit den teig jetzt braucht ja
auch keine küchenmaschine mehr
und dann werde ich es trockenen zutaten
also mehl backpulver und speisestärke
vermischen und hinein 7
das ganze wird dann mit einem
schneebesen ganz kurz verrührt so dass
ihr ebenso wenig luft wie möglich raus
schlag
und dann wird der teig einfach
eingefüllt in die backform und muss dann
wandeln sich grad etwa 20 minuten
gebacken werden ihr müsst auf jeden fall
die stäbchen probe machen also mit dem
zahnstocher reinstecken und wenn nichts
mehr dran klebt dürfte den teig
rausnehmen und so werde ich ihn hinein
geben
abkühlen lassen und dann sehen wir uns
wieder meint eigesetzt gebacken hat
exakt 20 minuten gebacken und war dann
durch
und so schickt er jetzt aus und ihr
könnt jetzt hier sehen dass da hier am
rand leicht ausgelaufen ist also so
diese menge das ist wirklich noch normal
weil das einfach ein flüssiger teig auch
ist es ist kein biskuitteig der sehr
standfest ist weil imbiss betreibt führt
meier kein öl oder kein wasser hinzu und
bei diesem biskuitteig dieser öl teig
bei dem fügt man eben noch wasser hinzu
und öl
dadurch wird der teig natürlich etwas
flüssiger ihr könnt dem auch
entgegenwirken wenn ihr sagt okay ich
möchte dass da nix ausläuft dann könnt
ihr den teig in etwas also diese
backform in etwas backpapier einschlagen
das macht man einfach so dass man die
backform auf backpapier gibt und dann
von außen nach innen eben das backpapier
einschlägt und dann könnt ihr den ball
kam sogar hochheben und seht dass das
packpapier einfach dran hängen bleibt es
ist wie so ein doppelter boden eben
drunter und das verhindert einfach das
auslaufen
natürlich müsst ihr aber auch immer
darauf achten dass der ofen vorgeheizt
ist und dass er den teig einfach in der
form nicht so lange stehen lassen denn
wenn ihr entstehen lässt nimmt er sich
eben findet er seinen weg und läuft
hinaus
ich werde meinen teil jetzt komplett
auskühlen lassen und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder
und wenn der teig dann komplett
ausgekühlt ist dann könnt ihr weiter
arbeiten und zwar wenn ich fit zu machen
dass ich vom teig so eine kleine schicht
abschneide
und diese dann zerbröselt und später als
topping drauf gebe ihr könnt damit auch
den teig so ganz lassen dann die erdbahn
und die creme drauf geben und dann zum
beispiel eine schotterschicht drauf
geben
aber weil ich jetzt keine show
geschichte machen möchte sondern euch
einfach den ganz einfachen trick mit den
streuseln zeigen möchte zeige ich euch
das jetzt und zwar benutze ich jetzt
wieder dieses werkzeug meine torten säge
dafür weil ich einfach damit schöne
gerade stück herausschneiden kann
es war stelle ich mir das jetzt ein ich
mich natürlich jetzt nicht so viel
abschneiden sondern einfach nur was ganz
kleines und kann jetzt hier das einfach
verstellen
muss ich einfach ein bisschen
zusammendrücken und also torten
schneidern gibt's einfach echt
unterschiede wie tag und nacht
ich hatte dieser schon mal gesagt dass
ich einen apfel von lidl oder aldi ich
weiß gar nicht mehr
und da war einfach ist grottenschlecht
hat wie man den teig zerstört weil
einfach dieser draht viel zu glatt war
und dieser trat ich eben geredet wie so
eine kleine gegeben um ihr seht da kann
ich richtig schön einmal durchsägen mine
eingeschlossen sich torten ja besser
schneiden wenn sie ein bisschen stehen
aber ich möchte jetzt einfach gleich
weiter arbeiten und dann nehme ich mir
jetzt einfach den oberen teil könnte er
der muss ja sowieso zerbröselt werden
und ihr seht richtig wie luftig und
feucht und lecker 30 der kameramann
streckt immer schon die hand aus hier
ein stück zum probieren
jetzt nehme ich mir einfach der torten
rette war hier einmal schön drunter und
kann den teig auf eine tortenplatte
setzen ich habe jetzt leider nur einen
teller das hört man noch richtig feuchte
sterben
und jetzt sitze ich hier einfach meinen
tortenring außen damit gleich die cremig
ausläuft und jetzt nehme ich mir meiner
erdbeeren
die sind alle schon gewaschen und da
müsst ihr immer aufpassen dass er die
erdbahn erst dann wenn ich sie auch
gebraucht denn wenn die gewaschen sind
wenn sie richtig im addison sowieso
empfindlich da muss man richtig sorgsam
damit umgehen
und wenn sie gewaschen sind weil sie
einfach schneller schlecht also das
heißt immer erst waschen wenig
verbrauchen wollt oder wenig zu essen
wollte ansonsten werden sie richtig
matschig und die habe ich jetzt schon
gewaschen wie gesagt wer jetzt hier den
stielansatz entfernen
und wenn sie dann halbieren und starr
ins rhein ringsherum setzen und zwar in
vernich das hier einfach ganz knapp am
stiel weil diesen strom wollen weil ich
mit drin haben und ich habe die s bahn
ausgesucht sie ungefähr gleich groß sind
also natürlich sind es ja natürliche
produkte sind immer alle unterschiedlich
groß aber wenn ja welche erwischt die
eben gleich groß sind ist das perfekt
weil es dann im anschnitt nämlich
richtig toll aussieht
ich hab gar nicht gesagt dass wir etwas
brauchen aber es war klar das wäre dann
braucht und zwar habe ich hier so ein
schälchen erdbeeren des in ungefähr 500
gramm
natürlich kommt darauf an welche
tortenring größe eben nutzt und dann
halbiert die einfach und setzt sie dann
mit der schnittkante nach außen in den
tortenring
und die restlichen erdbeeren die könnte
ich jetzt auch halbieren und da
reingeben damit man die torte später
einfach besser durch schneiden kann
werde ich sie jetzt etwas klein würfeln
das mache ich direkt in die torte reihen
als ich brauch jetzt auch kein
schneidebrett und da kann es einfach
später besser schneiden
so sieht es jetzt also bei mir aus ich
habe das jetzt hier auch schön verteilt
und habe das auch so ein bisschen flach
gedrückt einfach dass es so ein bisschen
ebenmäßig ist und jetzt kann ich da eben
die creme herstellen und die creme
darauf verteilen
für die creme habe ich hier 200 gramm
schlagsahne 125 gramm magerquark 200
gramm joghurt da habe ich jetzt den
vierprozentigen ihr könnt aber auch
annehmen oder nur quark benutzen also
dann noch mal eben 200 gramm dazu ihr
könnt ihr braucht den quark durch
joghurt ersetzen also hauptsache ihr
habt 200 plus 125 gramm und da könnt ihr
wie gesagt auch einen joghurt nehmen mit
weniger prozent fällt oder mit mehr und
je mehr fettanteil ihr habt umso
cremiger wird einfach dann eure creme
und deswegen habe ich jetzt jeden
4-prozentigen und mit dem schmeckt es
richtig lecker hier habe ich noch 50
gramm zucker eine tüte magazine das
kennt ihr jetzt bereits schon das ist
ein pflanzliches geliermittel aber ihr
könnt stattdessen auch sechs blätter
gelatine nehmen oder eine twitter
gemeinde gelatine aber wie ihr wisst
drive ich lieber gern zum pflanzlichen
produkt weil ich es einfach besser finde
und hier habe ich noch etwas
vanilleschote können dann natürlich auch
weglassen oder auch zum beispiel etwas
zitrone benutzen erfüllung werde ich
jetzt so vorgehen dass ich zuerst die
magazine bearbeite weil die nämlich
aufgekocht werden muss und dann eben
etwas abkühlen muss und waren die dann
abkühlt kann ich schon mal die sahne
steif schlagen und den quark verrühren
bei der ak tine macht ihr das jetzt so
dass er sie in einen kleinen topf gibt
etwa 200 milliliter wasser mit dazu gibt
da könnt ihr zum beispiel auch etwas
saft nehmen oder zitronensaft aber ich
möchte heute einfach mal tragen halten
weil ich möchte dass die creme nach
joghurt schmeckt dann verrät ihr das
ganze schön mit einem schneebesen und
nachts das aufkochen gemeinsam und wenn
es dann auf gekocht hat lass dir das
ganze zwei minuten lang mindestens
köcheln einfach damit die akademie ihre
binde fähigkeit eben erreicht und dann
eure creme später gut gebunden wird die
akademie werde ich dann apfel in ein
kleines gefäß damit sie eben schneller
abkühlen kann und wird jetzt die sahne
steif schlagen und anschließend denkt
und den joghurt bearbeiten was passieren
wird was würde dann fällt er kuchen
leiter zusammen weil dann fehlt einfach
diese bindekraft und joghurt und sahne
und quark die sind nicht so stabil und
wenn man dann den kuchen anschneiden
dann läuft so am rand die creme runter
und wir wollen ja dass der kuchen
wenn er eben angeschnitten wird schon
die form behält und jedes stückchen auch
ein stückchen bleibt und nicht zu einem
kleinen haufen zusammen quält und dann
gibt er einfach eure sahne in eure rolle
schiffe können dann natürlich auch
wieder ohne küchenmaschine machen und
mit einem handrührgerät ohne
handrührgerät wird sehr anstrengend und
dann lasse ich die sahne bei höchster
stufe schön steif schlagen und wenn die
sahne dann steif geschlagen ist
da werde ich jetzt kühl stellen und so
lange die quarkmasse zubereiten und hier
gebe ich jetzt einfach den quark hinein
den joghurt den zucker da es auch besser
wenn ihr puderzucker nimmt habe ich
jetzt aber vergessen das vanillemark und
jetzt wird es ganz kurz verrührt und das
stelle ich jetzt so lange in der
kühlschrank hier könnte jetzt auch sehen
dass dieser yoko ziemlich flüssig ist
also nicht so schlecht wie ein normaler
quark aber diese schlimmen deswegen
haben wir ja auch die ak tine und jetzt
gebt ihr etwas von diesem joghurt mit
routine und verrät ich schön
die akademische beantworten und das
machen wir einfach damit sie jetzt nicht
anfängt der oberfläche zu verlieren wenn
wir das jetzt nämlich hier ein kippen
würden wird es obendrauf studieren und
er hätte zu platine oder ein stückchen
wird jetzt durch ganz schnell und füllte
schönherr wein
und er steht jetzt auch dadurch dass ich
es 200 milliliter wasser genommen hat
sind auch seit flüssig geworden aber die
akademie steht bereits das sind von 30
grad und deswegen wird es jetzt auch
gleich wieder fest ich werde sie jetzt
bevor ich die sahne hinzufügen etwas in
den kühlschrank geben wird aber jede
minute spätestens reinschauen
weil es jetzt wirklich sehr schnell geht
also ihr seht jetzt schon sie es jetzt
schon etwas besser geworden
ich möchte nämlich einfach nicht dass
die sahne auch flüssig wird und deswegen
warte ich bis das etwas tailliert ist
ich sehe dass die creme ist schon
deutlich fester geworden ist jetzt habe
ich noch zwei tricks für euch um zu
kontrollieren ob die creme auch fest ihr
wird nehmen die anderen kleinen löffel
und gibt etwas creme auf einen großen
löffel und so stelle ich das jetzt in
den kühlschrank und wenn dann danach
noch etwa fünf bis zehn minuten
das nicht mehr läuft also so wie hier
wenn es dann fest bleibt wisst ihr die
creme wird später fest werden weil man
muss immer aufpassen wie viele aktive
nimmt man für wie viel creme und so
weiter und das ist so der eine tipp mit
dem genie und ich möchte jetzt diesen
vorgang etwas beschleunigen weil wir
einfach gerade wenig zeit haben und
weiter wollen und ich nehme es einfach
etwas an apart und gibt es mit dazu ihr
kennt das ja schon benutze ich ja
ziemlich oft weil es einfach sofort
geliert und ich möchte nicht warten
müssen wie sich dann die torte
anschneiden kann und geht jetzt einfach
etwas am apparat mit in die creme und
ihr seid jetzt die creme ist jetzt schon
richtig schön fest geworden und den rest
erledigt dann einfach das zahnrad und
die ak tine im kühlschrank und ich kann
jetzt direkt meine steif geschlagene
sahne unterheben
und dann könnte die creme auch schon
über die erdbeeren geben
jetzt verteidigt es einfach schön mit
meiner winkel palette geht natürlich
auch einem teig sauber aber so geht's
schneller und max schön glatt streichen
so das muss jetzt auch gar nicht ganz
glatt gemacht werden weil da nämlich
später noch eine schicht rüberkommt und
dann gebt ihr die torte etwa zwei bis
drei stunden in den kühlschrank
ich werde jetzt allerdings in die kultur
geben also ich schon jetzt ein bisschen
weil es jetzt einfach bei uns schnell
gehen muss und weste da glaube ich so
etwa eine halbe stunde drinnen lassen
bis ich dir anschneiden kann und weiß
natürlich vorher erstmal fertig
dekorieren und zerlegten wenn man die
tore macht braucht man wenn man die
torte ganz normal macht braucht man
ungefähr also von anfang bis jetzt habe
ich vielleicht so eine stunde gebraucht
vielleicht ein bisschen länger wegen der
wartezeit aber auf jeden fall also
maximal eineinhalb stunden maximal zwei
stunden mit wartezeit zwischendurch und
dann nochmal die wartezeit danach geht
schnell und man kann er zum beispiel den
teig auch schon einen tag vorher machen
oder morgens und kann dann einfach was
ich arbeiten gehen und wenn man
heimkommt und der teig abgekühlt ist
kann man dann die creme mit den
tortenboden und mit der mit den
erdbeeren belegen die creme drauf und
dann gibt es ja wirklich ganz schnell
also das ist eigentlich immer so die
wartezeit mit dem backen und dann eben
noch mal mit dem abkühlen und alles
andere ist wirklich sehr schnell als
vorbereitungszeit ist vielleicht eine
halbe stunde
die torte sollte man natürlich ziemlich
schnell auf essen weil da frische
erdbeeren drin sind also ich würde mal
sagen wenn ich sie heute zubereitet und
die erdbahn heute schneide würde ich sie
heute und maximal morgen noch essen
vielleicht auch noch übermorgen aber
dann werden die erdbeeren auch schon
matschig meine tochter ist schön
abgebügelt also wie gesagt hat ich setz
kurz im gefrierfach um so ein bisschen
zu schummeln
und so sieht sie jetzt auf woran sehe
ich das fest ist einfach wenn ich
schüttel bewegt sich die oberfläche
nicht mehr mit und jetzt nehme ich hier
meinen teil und zerkrümelt den in meinem
teller
jetzt nehme ich mit den und gebt ihn
einfach mal drauf
so viel wie ihr möchtet und verteilte
devise maulwurf hoch und fast wenn ihr
könnt ja auch andere früchte nehmen wir
keine edberg nimmt halt bananen oder
andere sachen birnen und jetzt habe ich
hier so ein paar yogurette
schokoladenriegel und die werden jetzt
zerschneiden und hier noch etwas
dekorieren
und dann könnte das einfach darauf legen
und dann gebe ich jetzt einfach noch so
zwei hälften drauf und die torte ist
fertig natürlich muss ich jetzt erst
noch den rand entfernen und so sieht
jetzt mein fertiger etwa schoko teig
schokokuchen aus die schokotorte und ich
finds echt richtig hübsch grad weil hier
an der seite die erdbeeren so schön
rausgucken und der richtet aleker den
schneide ich jetzt heute nicht an weil
mein mann den morgen mit ins geschäft
nimmt also die kollegen dürfen sich
schon mal freuen
und er fragt ja auch immer ganz oft wäre
die ganzen kuchen und torten ist als ich
muss das echt verteilen ich probiere
immer alles und es auch immer gern
also wir sind bestimmt jeden tag kuchen
oder gebackenes oder irgendwas aber das
muss man natürlich immer weg geben das
ist übrigens auch der geheim- trick um
schlank zu bleiben es einfach selber
viel kochen und backen wald und ist nur
von dem allen viel weniger weil was ja
eigentlich jeden tag wieder selber
nachmachen kann dieses rezept gibt es
natürlich nachzulesen auf see lässt
orten welt.de
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr da
vorbeischaut wenn ihr mir einen
kommentar last und auch eine bewertung
und für den sonntag habe ich mir
überlegt dass ich da entweder einen
nachgemacht video mache kein nach
gemacht ich wollte klassik machen und
zwar entweder einen rhabarberkuchen oder
einen käsekuchen oder ich mach ein eis
und zwar würde ich das so machen dass
ich es einmal mit der küchenmaschine
mache also mit der kitchenaid mit der
eismaschine
die zweite möglichkeit ist mit dem
thermomix und die dritte möglichkeit
ohne eismaschine und es wird ihnen ein
video verpacken einfach damit ihr seht
wie kann ich zum beispiel dieses wald
preis ein mal eben mit eismaschine
einmal mit küchenmaschine mit der
thermomix und einmal ohne machen und das
wirklich so verpacken
da würde ich hätte ich ganz gerne dass
er das mal abgestimmt und sagt ob ihr
lieber jetzt es aussehen würde
oder eben diesem classic entweder
rhabarberkuchen oder käsekuchen und
jetzt wünschen euch noch ganz viel spaß
mit schönen tag und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder bis bald